und bei mir ist noch immer unser politik
chef jan schäfer wir haben jetzt also
die beschlussvorlage vorliegen was sind
da die ersten sachen die ins auge
stechen
also die beschlussvorlage besagt ja das
ist das papier die grundlage auf der
gleich die bundeskanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten diskutieren wird das
wird sicherlich ein paar stunden dauern
denn es gibt ein paar punkte in dieser
beschlussvorlage die noch mit xx
gekennzeichnet sind und das sind dann so
die dinge über die man sicherlich reden
wird aber bis jetzt kann man schon sagen
die bundesregierung das hat man gerade
auch ja in der pressekonferenz mit ihren
sparen gemerkt will also nochmal
insgesamt verschärfen
das umstrittene beherbergungs verbot
über das wir in den vergangenen tagen
viel viel berichtet wurde fällt nicht
sollen nicht fallen
das geht hier aus dieser
beschlussvorlage auch deutlich hervor
denn darin wird verwiesen auf die
regelungen die eigenen einige
bundesländer haben und es gibt einen
wirklich großen appell in dieser
beschlussvorlage dass menschen aus
risikogebieten innerdeutsch auch nicht
verreisen sollen so und dann ist der
hinweis noch auf diese auf diese
beherbergungs verbote die es gibt
insgesamt sollen maßnahmen jetzt schon
ergriffen werden kontakt beschränkungen
beim incidents wird von 35 das bedeutet
wenn innerhalb von sieben tagen auf
100000 einwohner gerechnet 35 menschen
an krone erkranken dann wird es bereits
zum beispiel eine sperrstunde geben ist
nicht ganz klar man die in kraft treten
soll
bars und clubs sollen dann zum beispiel
auch geschlossen werden und wenn dieser
wert auf 50 oder darüber steigt dann
sollen beispielsweise auch bordelle
geschlossen werden dann wird auch die
zahl derjenigen mit denen man sich im
öffentlichen raum noch treffen kann auch
noch mal reduziert darüber wird nachher
nochmal zu diskutieren sein dass wir die
bundeskanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten machen und auf jeden
fall wird die masken pflicht in
öffentlichen einrichtungen öffentlichen
räumen möglicherweise auch in büros auf
jeden fall verschafft werden
ja also incident 235 das ist ja jetzt
weitaus niedriger als die 50 die wir
bisher hatten und dann sollte schon zu
strengeren maßnahmen kommen wird auch
über privatfeier noch mal neu diskutiert
viele menschen fragen sich jetzt
natürlich wie viel darf ich dann noch zu
hause machen wenn der geburtstag im
restaurant beispielsweise wegfällt ist
das auch noch mal ein thema das dann
heute hier neu aufgedeckt wird genau das
kommt aus der beschlussvorlage auch
schon
heraus das ist noch mal um die frage
gehen wird da gibt es jetzt noch keine
konkreten zahlen aber wie kann wer oder
mit wie viel personen darf ich
beispielsweise dann überhaupt noch
zusammen sein
es wird eindringlich in dieser
beschlussvorlage davor gemahnt man soll
sich ein bisschen zurück dem auch
wirklich überlegen ob feiern in dieser
zeit jetzt notwendig sind und wir haben
sie dabei ja sparen
gerade eben auch gehört er noch mal
gesagt hat wir müssen eigentlich jetzt
ein bisschen auf freiheit verzichten um
die freiheit die wir bisher hatten dann
vor corona auch möglichst zügig wieder
zu erlangen er hat das sparbuch
verglichen der vergleich hinkt
vielleicht gerade in zeiten wo es gar
keine zinsen ergibt aber hat gesagt
heute was zurücknehmen damit wir künftig
einen mehrwert bekommen wie man das beim
spanier auch macht einen euro ins
sparschwein stecken um dann 110 120 in
späteren jahren zu haben vergleich ein
bisschen aber das war so seine
terminologie wie verlässlich ist denn
jetzt dieser dieser entwurf den wir hier
vorliegende haben wie viel kann sich
daran tatsächlich noch verändern um 14
uhr treffen die ministerpräsidenten ja
erst mit der kanzlerin zusammen da kann
sich sicherlich noch einiges verändern
die kanzlerin war gestern schon mal mit
den ministerpräsidenten der union
zusammen das treffen hat ja roundabout
vier viereinhalb stunden gedauert und da
gab es auch viel gesprächsstoff und
natürlich sehen dass ministerpräsidenten
zum teil ganz unterschiedlich es gibt
länder mit sehr niedrigen
infektionszahlen es gibt länder mit
höheren infektions seines gibt
ministerpräsidenten nächstes jahr eine
landtagswahl beispielsweise haben wie
herr haseloff in sachsen-anhalt also da
gibt es auch ganz unterschiedliche
interessenlagen nicht zu vergessen
natürlich den kampf um die cdu-spitze
bzw auch die kanzlerkandidatur in der
union also zu glauben dass diese
beschlussvorlage zu eins zu eins durch
geht und die xc noch ausgefüllt werden
ich glaube das wäre falsch da wird
sicherlich heute viele diskussionen noch
geben die spd-regierten länder und baden
württemberg grün regiert und thüringen
von der linkspartei linken
ministerpräsident regiert sie dann auch
dabei so und das wird sicherlich ein
sehr interessanter intensive austausch
werden und es sind ja auch erstmals seit
beginn der korona pandemie alle
ministerpräsident wieder physisch im
kanzleramt und nicht per videoschalte
zugeschaltet
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren